my name is Park I see more that's
obviously of admin the company that
makes the shower let's clean up with
hidden species even forming around
either number one here at shadow we have
absolutely no preference as to who lives
here in the box number two
president-elect Erdogan has done nothing
wrong with the funding over all these
many helpful suggestions about how to
technology actually work we have some
routine why can't I see baited very
expected bombs in a result that
prevented us from tabulated all the
votes but how many countries would be
thrilled to have seventy percent of your
phone's camera a lot people are
suspicious and shadow because none of
the people that work on our apps have
names and Social Security numbers and
maybe their finger place if it bugs off
all of our points are completely unknown
even to me if I'm the CEO I can show up
in this USB file on my desk I put it in
your computer and it does what it does
absolutely did you shadow my note was
left on that poor people painful kind of
you existed when I got to that painful
right and she was an attorney I was
kidnapped by two words meaning that they
do be the truck and total sensory
deprivation and twelve me out to these
old formats in the middle of the school
and they sat at this desk while I was
still sitting right now this is one of
the greatest companies I've ever had the
privilege to lunch
I've only been fed protein kids at war
and men in suits come in here from time
to time and speak language that I can't
recognize I love this company one time I
was blindfolded me down the bar and now
I'm someone else I don't know there let
the man who first hired me said shut the
I say nothing